[Musique]
on pourrait penser un que courir 26
marathon en 26 jours ce n'est pas être à
l'écouté de soi en réalité un et bien
c'est tout l'un vers ce que j'ai vécu
j'ai été à l'écouté de moi intensément
présente durant tout ce périple où j'ai
couru de québec à halifax et de paris
jusqu à chartres en france 1 et en toute
sincérité
eh bien j'ai pas toujours été à l'écouté
de ma vie non en fait en 2016 à l'âge de
37 ans je vivais sur le pilote
automatique
vous savez le fameux métro boulot dodo
cette vie monotone et répétitive où tout
va vite le travail la famille le souper
le bain des enfants et cetera et cetera
alors c'est sûr qu'au fur et à mesure
progressivement sans vraiment m'en
apercevoir
eh bien je me suis éloigné de mes
aspirations de mes rêves je me suis même
renfermé complètement sur moi même un
peu comme un escargot là qui rentre dans
sa coquille et qui pense d'ailleurs
qu'on la voit plus je ne parlais plus du
tout à personne ni même à mon propre
mari alors c'est sûr que lui a un jour
et bien inquiets ils me demandent si je
laime encore la réponse elle aurait dû
être bien simple elle aurait dû être
oui sans aucune hésitation mais rien
n'est sorti de ma bouche à ce moment là
pourquoi je ne sais pas en tout cas
c'est sûr que lui de son côté et bien il
me dit qu'il serait peut-être préférable
de faire une pause dans notre couple
voire même de se séparer un et là là
pour moi ça a été émis un vrai coup de
fouet ce n'est pas du tout ce que je
voulais et pourtant c'est un petit peu
ce que j'ai provoqué malgré moi
alors voyons j'avais des comportements
inhabituels 1 je me reconnaissais plus
là dedans je rencontre mon médecin deux
jours après et je lui raconte un petit
peu la situation à me pose des questions
et cetera que le diagnostic tombe elle
me dit que je suis en dépression
écoutez je me souviendrai toujours de ma
réaction
moment là je les regarder droit dans les
yeux et j'ai osé je sais même pas
comment j'ai fait j'ai osé pis je lui ai
dit non je dis non je pense pas on est
au mois novembre via un manque de
luminosité
je suis fatigué mais les gens en général
sont plus fatigués au moins de novembre
je pense que c'est plus le coup de blues
1 du mois de novembre ça va passer c'est
sûr j'étais complètement dans le déni
alors c'est sûr qu'à me faire partir
avec deux ordonnances
mais il ya une ordonnance en particulier
qui a retenu mon attention est en fait
c'était celle de marcher 30 minutes par
jour au début je me suis dit m fait une
blague c'est sûr non a été vraiment
sérieuse la docteure là elle voulait
vraiment que je marche 30 minutes par
jour
alors moi bah pensant que c'est c'est
facile ben je lui dis ok pas de problème
en fait tout compte fait ça a été une
grosse erreur de penser que c'était
facile
le lendemain matin je chausse mes
baskets
je n'ai même pas réussi à marcher 30
minutes j'en ai fait que de 10 et je me
souviens mais ça a été mais un vrai
supplice je n'avais aucune motivation
j'avais juste envie de rentrer à la
maison
mais à force de persévérer au fur et à
mesure eh bien j'ai réussi à marcher
mais 30 minutes tous les jours et par la
suite de jets recommencer la course à
pied qui est pour moi une passion un
alors c'est sûr que deux ans plus tard
et bien je suis au téléphone avec mon
frère qui lui compose avec une maladie
du cerveau la schizophrénie donc depuis
son adolescence et il me dit qu'il
aspire à une vie heureuse mais que c'est
impossible
et là je me suis revu deux ans
auparavant penser et dire un peu la même
chose si j'étais en total désaccord avec
lui je me suis on peut pas dire que
c'est impossible c'est pas vrai mais
d'un autre côté j'avais pas
particulièrement envie de lui dire ce
qu'il devait faire
ou de lui donner des conseils j'avais
plus envie à ma manière de faire prendre
conscience en fait de l'importance de
l'activité physique pour une bonne santé
psychologique un parce que je me dis pas
pour moi ça m'a aidé alors ça peut en
aider plus d'un alors de l'appeler je
raccroche avec mon frère je vais en
direction de mon ordinateur
j'ouvre google maps
et puis j'écris donc la destination de
québec jusqu'à chartres en france est à
dire jusqu où ils habitent et je vois la
dé la possibilité en fait de faire le
trajet à la marche je me suis dit hey
c'est une idée ça j'ai commencé à
étudier la possibilité je regarde tous
les kilomètres
ouais 1117 km si je fais 43 km par jour
ça me donne 26 jours ok ça ça me tente
ça j'ai envie de le faire ça ça me
ressemble
en plus de ça eh bien ça serait un
périple qui seraient remplis d'espoir
waouh
alors de là et bien je me suis entraîné
presque un an
en fait me préparer physiquement et
mentalement pour ce périple 1 et le 20
mai 2019
eh bien je prends le départ alors c'est
sûr qu'à partir de ce moment là je
pourrais vous raconter une multitude
d'histoires une multitude davanture
toutes différentes les unes des autres
que j'ai vécues lors de ce périple là
mais aujourd'hui je vais vous en
raconter une seule est en fait c'est
l'histoire de mes baskets une deux
paires de baskets qui mois accompagné 1
alors je vous les présente un tout
d'abord ici je vous présente violette
c'est comme ça que je les ai appelés en
fait violer tél
je les adore elles sont super légère
j'ai vraiment confortable dedans j'ai
une belle foule et je pensais vraiment
en fait que c'était avec elle que je
finirais ce périple là mais non pas du
tout elles m'ont quand même accompagner
un peu plus de 400 km mine c'est pas
elle qui m'ont qui m'a accompagné
jusqu'à la fin et je vous présente un
blue blue en fait bas avant je les
aimais pas vraiment c'était pas
particulièrement mais préférer à son
plus lourde
j'ai une foulée un petit peu moins
dynamique je tape un peu plus du talent
mais bon elles sont quand même masse
quand même confortable là je lui donne
sol et c'est avec elle d'ailleurs que
j'ai fini en fait ces périples là alors
je vous met en contexte il est 8h30 du
matin
j'entre dans le parc kennedy l'ex qui se
situe entre plaster rock et miramichi au
nouveau-brunswick
et j'entame le 11e marathon alors je me
souviens cette matinée-là sa santé bon
dans la forêt sa santé les pins et le
paysage était vraiment magnifique
il y avait un épais brouillard qui
m'empêchait de voir au loin un peu comme
si que c'était une journée mystérieuse
là qui s'annonçait à l'horizon un alors
je chausse mes baskets préféré bien sûr
je commence à courir ça va bien super
puis arrivés au septième kilomètre
jetant une gêne au pied droit alors
d'avant fêtes j'appelle mon
accompagnateur qui m'attendait en
voiture quatre kilomètres plus loin
puis je lui demande si c'est possible
pour lui de venir de venir me rejoindre
je sentais comme j'avais vraiment un
pressentiment
vous savez là le frais le pressentiment
de devoir être à l'écouté
là maintenant pas particulièrement dans
deux heures pendant trois heures ni même
ce soit maintenant maintenant alors je
prends le temps j'enlève mes baskets et
on chante je m'aperçois et bien que
j'avais une belle grosse ampoule
alors c'est sûr que bon bah avec
l'humidité et tous ces kilomètres
parcourus bien en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que mes pieds ont gonflé et
j'étais devenu trop serré en fait dans
les baskets
c'était là que j'ai compris rapidement
que ma paire de baskets préférez donc
violette qui m'avaient accompagné quand
même presque 430 km eh bien il était
temps pour elle de laisser la place à
une autre paire de baskets qui était
beaucoup plus adapté à mes nouveaux
pieds gonflés 1 c'est-à-dire violette
alors imaginez si j'avais complètement
ignoré en fait les signaux que mon corps
m'avait envoyé imaginez un si j'avais
fini mon marathon avec ma paire de
chaussures violettes dans quel état
aurait été mes pieds 36 kilomètres plus
loin pensez vous en faites trop
longtemps mais trop longtemps j'ai
ignoré les signaux que mon corps et mon
esprit m'envoyer un et je suis fier
d'avoir été à aller coûte d'avoir pris
ce temps de m'arrêter pour pouvoir
prendre soin de moi et mieux qu'on
in med avance t1 donc avoir été à
l'écouté et avoir pris ce temps d'arrêt
et bien ça ne m'a n'ont pas permis
d'aller plus vite mais ça m'a permis
d'aller plus loin
voilà merci
[Applaudissements]